it's so good to see you to have my
witchy sabrina back in my life how are
you feeling
i'm feeling amazing now it's always good
to see you you always make it feel like
sabrina is actually happening to me like
it wouldn't be a press day without land
like i
love you so much i was so excited to
hear that our long-awaited sabrina
riverdale crossover was finally
happening what was going on behind the
scenes to make this finally be the
moment that we've got you up to
vancouver on the riverdale set break it
down for him oh oh my gosh it was a
journey it felt like it took forever to
get there but basically i was working
and just schedules
aligned at a certain point and
we just kind of said okay we're gonna
we're gonna really do this let's see how
we can work it out and fit it in and
before i knew it i was on a plane up to
vancouver and it was just like old times
it was wonderful feels like it's been
centuries doesn't it okay let's talk
about the episode by now everyone has
seen it but you were in river vale and
not river dale so is it a true crossover
in your mind kiernan i think it's a
crossover because it's still the show
riverdale
so it should it should count as a
crossover though i don't think that it's
the last i mean i hope not i hope we see
her again i hope this is a taste and i
hope it makes people want to see sabrina
actually go to riverdale like i really
think that there's something interesting
to be had back in riverdale and now that
we know that sabrina is back and she
could you know i think this was sort of
just setting everything up well
especially because it was so much fun to
see you and madeline share those scenes
together and in rivervale cheryl is
abigail is a witch like it was very
interesting it was a lot there's a lot
of problems together yeah you read the
script were you like i'm sorry i need
the cliff notes roberto catch me up
like what is happening here so yes i do
think that a simple streamlined
riverdale sabrina episode could also
happen that i would love to see because
who did you not get to interact with
directly i mean i just got mad which was
incredible because we've never hung out
before and i think she's the greatest so
we had so much fun but
i mean i want that like i want like a
sabrina archie moment
how iconic i mean it would be so good
and i feel like i'm sure in one
iteration in the comics they must have
gotten together archer's behind everyone
absolutely we have a lot of mutual
friends share a lot of the same
interests but the last time you and i
talked chilling adventures of sabrina
came to an end it was an ending that you
or i did not see coming we have sabrina
trapped in the afterlife with nick so it
was kind of like a bittersweet ending is
she still there i don't know i don't
think so given the fact that she went to
rivervale i would think that she found
her way out i don't think she'd want to
die i don't think sabrina's the type of
girl that would just die and deal with
it like i i really do think that there's
no chance that she would not find her
way out i don't think they would stand
for it i just don't like i think you
know they had the funeral because you
have to do that sort of thing but i
think after a minute they would all be
like okay we're not gonna deal with this
and go get her there is no death for
witches it's been a year since the show
ended almost two years since you filmed
it i believe so you've had time to
digest it you've had time to see the
fans reactions to the ending how are you
feeling about it now having almost two
years away from this role i feel great
about it i feel so good about what we
did and so i'm still so excited by all
the stuff that we did it felt like every
episode was just a marathon that we were
sprinting
and we did it somehow and i'm so
immensely proud of just everyone in that
show and what we were able to accomplish
in the in the time that we had and you
know as time goes on my heart just gets
bigger and bigger for it like i just i
love sabrina so much i always will so it
doesn't sound like you closed the
chapter on this character would you be
open to stepping back into her witchy
shoes again yeah i mean i always kind of
say that like i'll play sabrina any
chance i get i think that it always has
to be right and it has to align and it
has to be good for the moment but yeah i
love her i would be hard-pressed to say
no to doing a sabrina anything okay good
all right i'm like so for all the fans
out there who are like we want a reunion
movie they can still hold out hope
totally i know what you're going to say
but somehow i'm responsible for what's
happening i'm never the one that's
greenlighting these things like i'm i'm
always down one thing to know about me
is i'm perpetually down to reprise
sabrina sally anytime
say it i'm there there's other people
that have to do more
i'm i'm i'm a yes woman i mean admin is
still by far my favorite drama i can
re-watch it any time and there were
rumors right after it ended about a
sally draper spin-off was that a real
thing is that something that was real i
don't think the rumors were real i think
it was more just kind of like excitement
and uh curiosity around it but never say
never never say never do you ever think
about what she would be up to yeah in
many different eras i think about the
fact that she would probably still be
alive
like god willing like i think that you
know thinking about sally now now is
kind of a really funny thing like if
this spin up was i would obviously not
play her but like if this spin-off was
literally her in like 2022 would be kind
of wild and amazing but also yeah i do
think about you know what she would get
up to in the 70s and the 80s and i think
that's wildly exciting i would just
picture her like living in the 90s being
a mom
and what that would be like
there's so many eras there are so many
euros ahead i guess what's next for you
geeks what are you up to i just wrapped
a movie called wildflower a couple weeks
ago which was so fun and wonderful jean
smart and jackie weaver are in it and
alex did dario and charlie plummer and
it's just it's a wonderful wonderful
movie and i'm so excited for people to
see it next year hopefully
and this summer i was filming white
house plumbers which is an hbo show with
woody harrelson and justin thoreau that
was amazing
2022 i'm excited i feel like i i worked
a lot in 2021 and then all the stuff
comes out the year after i love that
though so now we're going to get to see
a lot of you
yes i'll be around you know i do
anything to help a fellow witch we saw
sabrina come back in rivervale we saw
you share a bunch of really great scenes
with madelaine pitch me what is next in
addition to scene scenes with archie if
you could come back to riverdale
give me that that storyline what are you
pitching to roberto i want sabrina to
hook up with someone in riverdale
literally you didn't have enough of the
strong shippers from harvey or nick i
know but i just love it for her go
sabrina go i mean maybe it's selfish i
don't know i just think it'd be really
like i love sabrina when she's just
living her life i love her spell casting
don't get me wrong but i've done so much
of it that i do feel like sabrina having
like grounded
relational experiences especially with
characters that we already know and love
from riverdale oh my god
count me in
write my name in the in the book of the
beast we're here for it done
[Music]